Welcome back everyone, this will be my Marvel Fantastic Four video
for Adam Driver apparently he is going to be the new Reed Richards Mr Fantastic of the main
616 Marvel universe so we'll break it all down
if you're brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos Matt shackman
from wand division is making the Fantastic Four
movie really excited to see what he does with
the project but it's going to be set in the main
616 universe so for instance the John Krasinski
read Richards Mr Fantastic in the 838 Universe in
Doctor Strange Multiverse of Madness was meant to
be a completely different version of the character
it's so funny that Kevin cast John because the
fans had a dream of who the perfect rate Richards
would be and because it's an alternate universe
I think Kevin said let's make that dream come
true when they introduced that version of the
character he obviously said that he already was
married to sue storm his invisible woman from
that universe and he already had his children
Valeria Richards and Franklin Richards so there
already been a lot going on with the Fantastic
Four in the timeline of that universe but the big
change that Marvel is making is that for the
Fantastic Four movie they're introducing the
main version of the team from the main universe
that all these movies have been taking place on
earliest the movies that haven't been Multiverse
movies like Doctor Strange Multiverse of Madness
there might be some Multiverse stuff happening
during the movie because we are in the middle
of the Multiverse Saga obviously we're talking
about the incursions king the conquer everything
that's happening leaning up to Avengers 5 King
Dynasty and Secret Wars but this is them saying
that there's been a version of the Fantastic Four
team in the main Marvel Universe this whole time
and they'll be explaining why we haven't seen them
till now they've been a lot of theories about that
like have they not had the accident that turned
them into mutates like the cosmic storm that gave
them their powers yet when they introduced stored
during one division it seemed like The Logical way
for them to go because it was the beginning of
Marvel phase four and we knew they were going
to do fantastic for is that they would say that
the Fantastic Four characters were working for
sword and they were on a mission when they had
the accident that gave them their powers the
cosmic storm but the interesting report is that
now they're actually paying off a long-running
Easter egg that people had questions about during
Doctor Strange Multiverse of Madness there's a
scene during that movie when Doctor Strange
is first meeting Mr Fantastic in the other
Illuminati characters and he makes a joke about
them charting in the 60s Hello Steven Fantastic
Four didn't you guys chart in the 60s at the time
people wondered if that was meant to be an Easter
egg for the group The Fantastic Four in the 1960s
and the rumor is is they're actually going to use
that to say that that version in the main Marvel
Universe like his own Universe was the actual
Fantastic Four that had been displaced in time
like they got lost in the past and stuck there
for a while and through the course of their
movie they'll find a way to come back to the
events of present day like they'll make it back
to present day and that's why we haven't seen the
actual Fantastic Four characters until now like
they'll actually just be from the past technically
and then come into the future obviously them
casting Adam drivers Mr Fantastic is a bit of a
left turn I actually expected him to be cast for
a character like Doctor Doom just because he's
so dark and broody most of the characters that he
plays I feel like he'd be fantastic either way it
sounds like this version of Reed Richards they're
casting him for Mr Fantastic will be a much more
hardcore darker version of Reed Richards there
are reports that Marvel did approach him about
playing either Reed Richards or Doctor Doom and
it sounds like he wanted to play Reed Richards
more than he wanted to play Doctor Doom maybe he
wanted to avoid being Typecast you guys can let
me know what you think about the actual casting I
mean he's a fantastic actor I'm just interested to
see what they do with this version of the actual
group there have also been reports about casting
for Sue storm being pretty close to the Invisible
Woman Mila Kunis was spotted recently having a
meeting with Matt shackman the director of the
movie Allison Williams name was thrown around
and Jody cummer who I'd love to see play a more
unhinged version of Sue storm if Adam Driver is
going to be doing a darker more intense version of
Mr Fantastic no word yet on who would play Johnny
Storm or the thing Ben Grimm there were rumors
that the thing was going to have a cameo scene
during She-Hulk and like one of those meta type of
cameos but he'd still be a version of Ben Grim he
wouldn't have had his powers yet or it would have
just been an Easter egg for his character they did
have that weird meta post-credits scene teaser
with all the sneakers that featured Easter eggs
for like every single major comic book character
that Marvel has ever done including all the X-Men
characters Fantastic Four all the way bigger
versions of characters that Marvel hasn't done
yet are versions of characters that they're about
to do like Deadpool in Deadpool 3 he was featured
in the scene but they've actually been setting up
the Fantastic Four including Easter eggs for the
team for a long time since the very beginning of
Marvel phase four even the end of Marvel phase 3
like Spider-Man far from home the next big Easter
egg is the construction sign so when he swings
down you see the one two three in question
mark instead of the four with the different
colors the text reads we can't wait to show you
what comes next obviously that's a reference to
a bunch of different things in Marvel phase 4
is a reference to Marvel phase 4 itself like
we can't wait to show you all the new movies in
Disney plus Avengers spin-off series that we're
doing right now but as you probably spotted the
four numbers in the colors of the numbers also
correspond to the power sets of the Fantastic
Four so the one is red represents Human Torch
the two yellow represents the thing three blue
Mr Fantastic and the reason why you don't see the
four it's a question mark is because it's meant
to represent the Invisible Woman it's invisible so
you can't see the four then the last little Easter
egg here is when he swings down and they stand on
the street corner here at the intersection of
East 41st and Library way that's actually near
Yancey Street in the comics where the comic
book version of the Baxter building resides
there's also a really cool connection between
what's going on with all the quantum energy
the portals that Mr Fantastic and Doctor Doom use in
the MCU as well as king the conquer in the future
so like all these characters are connected
but according to Sam Raimi the director in
the writer of the movie The really cool doctor
Dooms scene happens when John krasinski's read
Richards of the a38 universe Fantastic Four
enters the room for the first time and this
is the clip of them talking about that just doing
commentary for the movie so really cool reveal if
you listen to the commentary Lynch was a pleasure
to work with Reed Richards of the Fantastic Four
so was John hello Stephen teleportation device he
uses to get into the scene is something we took
from the comics that's Dr tombs uh Doctor Doom's uh
time door appreciate it I'm platform Stephen but
it's not the Scarlet Witch that we fear and
while it is not Professor X's first time on
screen it is the first time we see that uh over
chair from the Animated Series Pete Richards is
my favorite Marvel Comics character so it was a
real honor to write his first entry I guess here
in the museum so there's a lot to unpack in that
John Krasinski Fantastic Four stuff that Sam Raimi
and the writer are talking about but the really
important part is all the stuff about Doctor Doom
they're confirming that read Richard's portal
technology is the same technology that the TVA
is using allowing him to travel across time and
space Not Just across space confirming that it's
based on their version of Doctor Doom's time travel
platform which is a huge comic book deep cut that
also confirms that he's using Quantum energy to
power it which was a big theory of ours like he'd
be using Quantum energy because the portal looked
very similar to TBA portals it's just that it's
blue colored instead of orange colored and we
know all of Kang or he who remains time travel
platforms the TVA portals that they use and Iron
Man's time travel platform during Avengers end
game is also powered by Quantum energy and if you
didn't realize too Iron Man's time travel platform
is also based on the concept from Doctor Doom's time
travel platform it's just a very different looking
kind of platform the one in Doctor Strange 2 is
more literally meant to be a copy of Doctor Doom's
time travel platform because the way it looks
here the reason why his portal would be blue in
Doctor Strange suit probably just because the
difference in the actual technology behind the
portals themselves the version that Kang uses in
the distant future the TVA technology would be
vastly vastly more advanced so this means in the
838 Universe John krasinski's Reed Richards had
already encountered a version of Doctor Doom makes
sense this is kind of like the wish fulfillment
most comic bookie universe that we've ever been
to inside the MCU Multiverse like every big Easter
egg from the comics mixed together in a bucket
put on the Illuminati together which themselves
are a huge Easter egg for the team in the comics
so this version of Reed Richards would have had a
version of their comic book history together with
Doctor Doom in school Doctor Doom's origin story is also
connected to the history of the Fantastic Four
when they were attending school they kind of did
a version of that backstory during the classic
Fantastic Four movies at Fox you know you made
a lot of folks at MIT feel like a junior high
science fair so you'll excuse me if I say for
the moment and this 838 Universe version of Reed
Richards developed his portal Technology based
on Doctor Doom's time travel platform meaning that
their Doctor Doom had already figured out time
travel and built a version of it like in the main
MCU 616 universe is Iron Man who's the one to be
the first to figure out time travel building his
time travel platform you have to imagine in this
universe it was Doctor Doom being the person to do
that and then this version of Reed Richards just
improves on that design basing his portal take on
it because the writer said that this version of
the 838 Universe Fantastic Four backstory and
Doctor Doom took more from the comics you have to
imagine that this universe's Doctor Doom also
created his time travel platform for similar
comic book reasons like all the Illuminati stuff
with them versus their their version of Thanos and
their version of Avengers Infinity war is all
completely separate from the Doctor Doom stuff
it sounds like I'm not expecting to see Doctor Doom
during this new Fantastic Four movie they might be
introducing him in some other MCU place but there
were reports they were actually going to tease him
during black panther wakanda Forever at one point
and he would have been behind the initial mission
to actually find vibranium underwater because
we're getting so close to the movie coming out
we'll probably see some more Easter eggs for his
character as well as the other Fantastic Four
characters everyone just posts all your reactions
about what's going on let me know who you want to
play the other Fantastic Four characters in the
comments Marvel's next big series that I'll be
doing episodes for is secret Invasion click
here for my brand new secret Invasion trailer
video and click here for all my new Guardians
of the Galaxy trailer videos and Easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!